this is the greatest headline that's
ever been written ever from Business
Insider Putin's nuclear threats are
pushing people like Trump and Elon Musk
to press for a Ukraine peace deal a
nuclear expert warns that's dangerous
wow
1984. here we are so good that is it's
the best you know the reason why it's
the greatest is because you could have
just said war is peace you know or
whatever yeah but they they really went
for it's very long yeah and it really
Nails the peace is dangerous right I
love that nuclear Winters actually
nuclear spring
well well hold on it is dangerous
because a small nuclear war could stop
climate change by killing tons of people
I guess yeah you guys saw that article
from Huntington post right no it's like
from 10 years ago it says could a small
nuclear war reverse climate change
yeah or even like lowering the carbon
footprint of the population yes the
carbon footprint is in the human beings
that are carbon yeah there you go okay
well let's let's see what they actually
have to say about this story
they say an understandable desire to
avoid a nuclear war could actually make
the world more dangerous if it means
rushing to implement a peace in Ukraine
that serves Russian interests an expert
told inside oh an expert
such a move which some influential
figures have called for risks setting a
precedent that Atomic blackmail is the
way to win Wars and take territory
troops can't otherwise hold a model that
could be copycated by even the weakest
nuclear-armed States and may only
succeed at delaying Another War
Pavel podvik an expert on Russia's
nuclear Doctrine
and capabilities of the UN Institute for
disarmament research said in a phone
interview from Geneva that such a deal
on terms deemed favorable by Moscow in
the wake of a battlefield of Battlefield
losses and an explicit response to the
kremlin's nuclear brinksmanship could
well make the world much less peaceful
the West supports Ukraine with weapons
and financial and moral and political
support giving that up and saying that
well you know we're too afraid of
nuclear threats and we just want to make
a deal that would certainly set a
precedent that would not be very
positive if you yielded this nuclear
threat once then what would prevent
Russia and the future or others to do
the same thing again how about nuclear
weapons in countries like the United
States and positioned in NATO and what
we're talking about right now is Ukraine
which is not a NATO member State not a
EU member State not in a position where
we should be sending weapons U.S
Personnel NATO citizens Special
Operations intelligence and engaging in
war with Russia hey how about that you
want to come and claim that I get the
point they're trying to make but it's
bunk Russia is having a border dispute
they invaded Ukraine it's a border
dispute that has not involved the United
States we've made it our business for
some reason that's the problem plus more
importantly it's historically inaccurate
look what happened during the Cold War
it was only because of de-escalation it
was only because of Peace deals we
didn't blow each other up and it didn't
lead to of course a misbalance of of
power and again this is just a lunatic
sociopla sociopathic bloodthirsty neocon
Warhawk that's spewing utter nonsense
literally trying to tell you that war is
peace what is about our current
trajectory playing nuclear war chicken
that is going to be leading to any kind
of resolution or peace as we're only
seeing escalations where's the
de-escalations where's the peace talks
where's the negotiations none of that
and it makes me nervous because it
reminds me of right before kovid and
people were just kind of talking about
viruses and all of a sudden the world
changed and the ways you didn't expect
was like it feels like that like right
before something big I got a pitch for
the U.N
for Joe Biden and for NATO all right you
want to get people in this war here's
how you play it you guys ever play
Fallout 3
no Luke yeah yeah
follow three a while ago you know fun
game huh it was yeah you never played it
no no what's the what's the nuclear
apocalypse happens and you come out of a
vault afterwards so you try and scavenge
the wastelands to survive
no no I'm just saying people really love
the game yeah oh oh my God
what's the what's the big deal huh right
yeah worst case scenario it's gonna be
just like Fallout you're gonna go into
the uh where do you go into the Lincoln
Land no there's a building in DC where
you get the Lincoln's repeater I can't
remember what it is but whenever I start
Fallout 3 I immediately go into there's
a government building you've got to
stealth past some ghouls ghouls are like
radioactively burned people and then you
open up this case and Lincoln's uh
Winchester repeater is in there it's an
excellent excellent weapon in the video
game so I'm just saying you know they're
saying uh it's peace is dangerous yeah
yeah this is not the pitch to get people
to be all in on nuclear war you gotta
have them play Fallout 3 and then be
like now wasn't that fun that could be
real life you could be eating moldy
cheese off the ground but yeah real this
time drinking out of toilets is another
thing you do in the game and then you
get radio radiation poisoning but but
too much radiation poisoning and you get
super powers yeah
yeah this is absolutely just just so
mind-boggling I saw this thing in this I
saw this article and I was like I need
the shirt don't nuke me bro because we
need this message out more than anything
else right now because it's absolutely
ridiculous the guardian wrote an article
today talking about how the West is
making plans to avoid Panic if Russia
uses a nuclear bomb that that that's an
absolutely crazy goal post line that
we're at right now that that is
absolutely ridiculous and according to a
lot of military strategists and even
Intelligence Officers they're saying
that it's between a 10 to 25 percent
chance that Russia will use a nuclear
bomb now the people in charge a lot of
the very powerful people a lot of the
people who control a lot of the
multinational corporations the big Banks
they have their bunkers they have their
survival of food they have everything
that they need they they don't have to
wager our risk anything else everyone
else is going to be paying for the
consequences of this for the these
stupid policies and decisions that don't
have any objective what's the the goal
here why are we doing this what's the
objective why can't we even ask and why
is the corporate U.S Western media
trying to Gaslight us into a full
all-out world war and it's simple
pull it up Serge
could a small nuclear war reverse global
warming from The Huffington Post the
article is real February 26 2011. it
says quote nuclear war could reverse
global warming boom if you are the
carbon they're trying to reduce that's
because it will end life on Earth I
don't even understand it will obliterate
life and human beings from from ever
existing like life as as we have it
right now we'll be over and it'll be
terrifying and if you're lucky to
survive you're going to suffer this is
so stupid and so backwards and again you
don't have to be pro-russia pro-pound to
call for peace and de-escalations with
negotiations no one's always going to be
perfectly happy no one's always going to
get what they want but at least for
Frick's sakes come to the table and
start talking just to each other and
have you guys seen the pictures in
certain Subways where they're putting up
posters like how to survive nuclear war
yeah but like are they serious
I think they're because we have tsas in
New York City yes funded by the city
more than one though I saw the other one
uh saw one of them there might be more
it's the woman saying like stay inside I
think I've seen that one but that's
conditioning right it's like kind of
just getting people used to the idea
which is she's like the big one hit
don't ask us how or why and the best
part is like the advice they give you
will not save you right right look at a
shower well no
no no no planes look look
so if you are in the blast radius I have
good news you won't even know what
happened the the Shockwave thermal
radiation detonation will kill you
faster than your brain can process
anything is happening you might hear a
whistle and then all of a sudden you
don't exist anymore now there's a
problem there's multiple layers to the
blast and you can be in just the um
there's a blast radius non-thermal which
is going to burn you and it's going to
like your ears will probably be bleeding
windows will be shattered you may be
seriously injured that's the worst place
to be and depending on the kind of bomb
they use some have maximum radioactive
yield you could be like watching
yourself melt in the fireball for like
an extended period of time so this PSA
really is for people who are outside the
blast radius completely and when they
said take a shower that's actually good
advice if you are covered in dirt and
grime you want to get clean as soon as
possible because the particles from the
radiation like the radioactive particles
iodine and things like that will get all
over you gotta take potassium iodine
pills but what they're basically saying
is if you live in like probably Harlem
or what's another good spot probably
Coney Island in that area or or Long
Island do these things because if you're
in Brooklyn Queens or Manhattan and they
nuke that's where it's going to be well
good I won't even know what happened
before I went on how it's probably going
to be Texas so that's really great well
yeah yeah I said at least I said it's a
good thing we don't live in some major
urban center like you know Austin or
whatever yeah I'm just like sweating
like oh okay well it's not just the
radiation it's the breakdown of society
of infrastructure of Clean Water of food
it's it's the nuclear fallout that of
course will be affecting the soils for
thousands and thousands of years and
over the weekend I actually watched a
documentary about soldiers in the United
Kingdom that were experimented on by
their government that launched a nuclear
weapon and they brought in the soldiers
just to see what would happen to them
they made them sign contracts and ndas
and they classified a lot of this
information so if they spoke out against
what happened to them they would be
charged which treason a lot of these
soldiers died a lot of these soldiers
became infertile a lot of these soldiers
came down with sicknesses and illnesses
that you can't even imagine and this is
a U.S sorry the UK government an
official military taking their soldiers
being like yeah we're just going to put
you right in front of this nuclear
nuclear blast to see what happened to
you and they were describing how during
the nuclear blast when they put their
their their hands in front of their face
to cover their eyes they could see every
bone every blood vessel in front of
their hands wow so so this is what
governments do they routinely sacrifice
people they sacrifice their own people
they murdered they do horrific
scientific experiments and if you think
the sociopathic monsters are are not
trying to start a nuclear war you're not
paying attention because that's exactly
what they're doing every single day
right now and there's like really
interesting Fallout that goes like by
Generations too because I watched a clip
on the plane actually here and there was
a guy who was around nuclear testing and
he didn't have any issues but he had a
daughter like born after he was involved
with it and the daughter by age 11 it
took 11 years for things to show up
started growing hair all over her face
and body uncontrollably because it
messes with your genes right so it's
like it just twists the Gene and uh she
actually died after that wow oh so it's
his daughter you know I was I was
thinking like maybe you know maybe you
become like a Hulk you know what I mean
well that'd be on the good end but I
don't know maybe uncontrollable rage
monster who can't like you know have
normal life I guess I don't think that
ever happened to anyone exposed to
radiation Tim oh well you know not yet
not yet I mean we might have a someone
grew hair all over her body I mean
that's kind of like a that's the Beast
he's there you go yeah so one X-Man came
from Wolverine that's the one looking at
this conversation in like six months and
like oh remember when we were talking
about this before it all went oh my God
I'm like oh my God we're gonna be
sitting in rubble eating cold beans
being like remember when we made that
joke it's gonna be in Austin well so the
point I was making before the show about
Austin was not literally Austin but I
was like
the first if we're dealing with like a
retaliatory strike or a threat
than Russia or whoever probably Russia
will not Target DC or a major city first
they'll Target a small town first for in
a shocking off strike so if you hit a
big city the rest of the country says of
course
if you hit a small town then everyone in
the country panics stops working locks
down or flees and that destroys the
economy outright right so that's
probably why they would do a lower yield
strike on a small City first I don't
think it would be DC simply because that
would be like deciding to shoot someone
in the bulletproof armor it's you know
it's like the probably the most heavily
fortified with bunkers Raven Rock has
got a 100 million dollar expansion have
you guys heard we talked about this
that uh we had when we had Drew Miller
and he mentioned that they're doing
expansion in Mount weather which is
nuclear bunker as well as and then he
mentioned Raven Rock I looked it up just
recently in August a 100 million dollar
contract to Raven Rock for a massive
expansion and they also did another uh
award another contract for Mount weather
for a major 65 000 square foot facility
they're not going to be done right away
but they're certainly thinking about
expanding their bunkers I would imagine
all of the surface-to-air missiles and
anti-nuke capabilities are centered
around DC specifically for this reason
so they'd probably hit if they wanted to
cause major disruption in this country a
major economic Center the reason why
Austin makes a lot of sense is because
the gigafactory is there like uh so
you've got San Francisco which would be
a huge Target probably because of the
tech sector and then you've got the move
over to Austin with gigafactory and
other you know let's just call it the
California brain drain to Texas and
Florida would make them Target as well
hit the economic centers they would
probably hit the North Dakota Frack
Fields seriously hindering our ability
to produce energy those are going to be
huge targets but it's not like the
political epicenter is is
it's probably a moderate Target but
thinking about like January 6th these
people thought that like by going in a
building they would have governmental
power or something they could it's like
dude it's not the 1600s so Putin Knows
Why hit DC the US government is is
digitally decentralized you need to you
need to economic and and
um Resource Centers Silicon Valley is
going to be a huge Target all of the
managerial power for all these all this
infrastructure you at Silicon Valley our
financial processing takes a major major
hit so we as a country need to be
diversifying all the stuff not just
because of the culture War but because
of the risk of hyper centralization in a
war you don't even have to do that you
just have to go to China and be like hey
stop selling them stuff then we're
screwed a big Pharma industry screwed uh
all the cheap plastic stuff screwed and
that again would would be a very serious
concept I'm hearing that Kanye's uh new
interviews got taken down the drink
Champs that was the one that he was
talking about you know got taken down
I'm not sure I haven't seen it let's uh
I'm trying to look it up right now
that's just someone just sent me there
right now so uh anyway you know nuclear
war and all that stuff so dude what was
the official reason that we hit Nagasaki
in hiroshimo not Tokyo Kyoto was it that
reason no no not the game you might want
to hit the capital you want to do a
smaller well a lot of Scholars argue one
it's because the Japanese were fighting
to the death two it was a kind of symbol
to show Russia and others he's asking
why not Tokyo why not tell you oh yeah
yeah so is it that you don't want to hit
the capital you want his smaller City to
spread more Panic well they were also
responsible for a lot of the
manufacturing and production of those
okay so the bigger War materials and you
you know the United States took over
Tokyo and it was a huge it's one of the
biggest cities in the world yeah the
civilian casualties would be immense I
Googled it stack exchange someone
responded Hiroshima the first city was
an important Army Depot and Port of
embarkation in the middle of an urban
Industrial Area okay it's a good radar
Target and it's such a size that a large
part of the city could be extend damaged
there are adjacent Hills which are
likely to produce a focusing effect
which would considerably increase the
blast damage wow that makes sense due to
Rivers it is not a good incendiary
Target there were also four other
possible targets kokura Niagara Yokohama
and Kyoto there were three criteria
choosing targets the target was larger
than three miles in diameter and was
important Target in a large urban area
the blast would create effective damage
the target was unlikely to be attacked
by August 1945 and East small and
strictly military objectives should be
located in much larger areas subject to
blast damage in order to avoid undue
risk of the weapon being lost due to bad
placing of the bomb interesting they say
the possibility of bombing The Emperor's
Palace was discussed it was agreed that
we should not recommend it but that any
action for this bombing should come from
authorities on military policy it was
agreed that we should obtain information
from from which we could determine the
effective effectiveness of our weapon
against this target oh they were testing
it
uh they wanted a good detonation to see
what the effects would be well there you
go huh interesting yeah they said it was
Tokyo was not a strategic value
uh if Japan were to be invaded
interesting make sense yeah military
Target there you go my friends so I just
want to say this as I as I do
um with the upcoming election to all of
you 18 to 25 year olds particularly 18
to 25 year old males whether you're
trans or not doesn't matter the US
government has already said it you must
sign up for the draft no and if you
don't and so let me just say if you find
yourself as an 18 to 25 year old male
for some reason voting demographic then
I will personally applaud you for your
sacrifice as you are loaded up as cannon
fodder in World War III by the people
you voted for so uh congratulations on
supporting the war effort me on the
other hand I'm gonna keep saying the U.S
should not be involved in the Ukrainian
conflict particularly at this point as
things have escalated to this degree and
we need to find a path towards peace
lest you be drafted thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday Friday at 8pm and if you want
more special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there